dunk over kendrick perkins is one of the
highest viewed NBA clips of all time
it's been seen by like 30 billion people
i just threw that out there don't laugh
at my guesstimate but it's made me think
do you ever get self-conscious now that
you're so well known for your dunking do
you ever start to go in for one and
think oh this one's gonna go viral oh
yeah that's normally what's going
through my mind is okay you gotta look
good this could be seen on YouTube yeah
exactly that's a good priority for you
yeah it's YouTube and then actually
making the play coach hates it but
whatever hey they got a deal yeah you
know it's it's funny but you're you're
so in the moment obviously when you're
when you're playing the game that you
just have a split second you make the
dunk and then maybe to cruise to later
oh I'm gonna hear about that one like I
dunked over 35 horses or something crazy
like that ya know normally there's no
horses have you been never not once so
Amy told me they were Pony on the horses
and the bombs that go on do your faces
while you're dunking are quite famous
quite unusual obviously you're not
you're you're concentric concentrating
in the game there's one it looks like
you're having brain freeze yeah I can't
control her so
but you guys get the point right yeah
you got the point you don't we don't
need to show you more of them but they
are amazing you see no teeth at you and
you've had friends that have given you a
hard time about your dunk face Oh
everybody everybody's giving me a hard
time including you know twice twice yes
that's true but I mean it's still best
friends like I can't like think to
myself like like the PR people will come
you know we do action shot like
autographs and they give them away and
the lady's like yeah we gotta got
another bad one again but every every
time every time so I guy thought about
actually like I need to like consciously
think to like turn to the camera and
smile or you know I mean like yes spice
it up or like what's nice you've been
working on it with us that we we've been
at my suggestion you thought you would
come up with better dunking faces and I
think these are quite impressive here's
one a new one there's put the wink and
yeah and then I think we have another
one right here these are very impressive
[Laughter]
newest players are not impressed with
what's happening what's next I think we
have another one here and yeah and I
like this one right here this is you
just checking out some your iPhone 6
yeah the iPhone 6 best dad for it you
know every athlete gets jeered during a
game by the opposing fans and I'm
thinking especially in basketball we
were sitting you're so close to the fans
you're sitting there and sometimes you
can probably hear really well worse of
course that you hear all the time and
most of the time it's not good but there
was one guy and I don't I think he might
do this to a lot of guys but we're lined
up for a free throw got really quiet I
just checked in the game my rookie year
and this guy goes hey Blake literally
the coolest thing you've done is stand
next to Kurt Thomas
I looked over at him I was just kind of
like it's pretty cool actually that was
that was the guy was a good we got
through to you yeah yeah most of them I
would think are not good there you
imagine it most of them are just like
hey you suck and you're like yeah I know
I know I don't I know yeah whatever I'm
not good at this game
you are fouled more than almost any
single NBA player and you rarely
retaliate and some people have said like
well maybe you've got to change your
attitude or change something that you're
doing like maybe you're being too soft
you're being too nice are you gonna
change it up this year ah well I mean I
took I took some karate lessons of
summer watch out guys no you know what
it's just kind of kind of personal
judgment call you know um but I might
have to I have to break out a karate
move or something all right what's it's
got it's got to be a hard line to walk
because you don't want people to be
thinking that they can fail you all the
time but at the same time you don't want
to tossed out of a game right and then
you get tossed out you get suspended you
fine then your team ends up you know
hurting more so it's kind of a fine line
and I hopefully in the moment I make the
right decision I don't ever want to like
be just swinging away and then be like I
[Laughter]
would like it if you were saying this is
a bad idea
I don't mean to be doing this
you